[Música]
ah
en medio de la crisis política y social
del país el índice de pobreza de
colombia aumentó 68 puntos porcentuales
respecto al año anterior hoy más de 21
millones de colombianos viven con cerca
de 90 dólares al mes
además el 15,1 por ciento de los
ciudadanos enfrenta la pobreza extrema
sin recursos incluso para alimentarse
adecuadamente colombia es uno de los
países más desiguales de la región una
situación agravada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 y que ha generado descontento e
indignación entre la población algo que
ha impulsado en las protestas que vive
el país desde el paro nacional del 28 de
abril y que ya han conseguido el retiro
de la reforma tributaria y de la salud
impulsadas por el gobierno pero no se
detienen ahí los miles que llevan en las
calles por 24 días la mayoría de ellos
jóvenes exigen un reparto de la riqueza
más equitativo y el fin de la violencia
policial
[Música]
cuando la pandemia de kobe 19 llegó a
argentina el país ya se encontraba en
medio de una profunda crisis económica y
en más de un año conviviendo con el
coronavirus la situación ha empeorado el
42 por ciento de los argentinos se
encontraba por debajo de la línea de la
pobreza en el segundo semestre de 2020
según las más recientes estadísticas
oficiales un año antes esa cifra era del
35 5% y si bien los salarios han
aumentado en estos meses más ha crecido
la inflación entre abril de 2020 y el
mismo mes de 2001 estuvo por encima del
46% según datos oficiales el gobierno
implementó diferentes planes de ayuda
para las personas y familias más
vulnerables y para apoyar las empresas
en este contexto de crisis pero con las
restricciones propias de la pandemia es
difícil prever que cuando se difundan
las cifras de pobreza del primer
semestre de 2021 no hayan aumentado aún
más que en el semestre anterior
[Música]
las familias viviendo en campamentos
aumentaron en chile 174 en 2019 según el
último catastro nacional de campamento
es presentado por techo chile y la
fundación vivienda en la región más
afectada del país fue la araucanía en el
sur donde el número de familias viviendo
en campamentos se incrementó en un 315%
y el número de campamentos en siguen un
128 por ciento chile venía teniendo un
descenso sostenido en el número de
campamentos desde 2011 pero la crisis
económica derivada primero del estallido
social y después de la pandemia ha hecho
que se produjera un crecimiento
vertiginoso y se produzca esta situación
alarmante según calificó el techo al
hecho de que casi 82 mil familias vivan
en las 969 campamentos que existen en
todo el país chile tenía uno de los
mejores indicadores de pobreza de toda
américa latina por detrás de uruguay
pero esta cifra subió de un 81 por
ciento a 12 como 1 por ciento en poco
más de un año además en 2020 la economía
chilena cayó un 58 por ciento su peor
registro en los últimos 40 años
[Música]